ممكن حل هذه المشكله كيف الطريقه لانقاذ
او المعالجه كيف ممكن خلق نظام عالمي جديد
من المسؤول
هو النظام اصلا
هذا النظام ابتدا منذ عقود عشرات السنوات
لما ننظر للتاريخ ونعتبر من التاريخ وخاصه
في الحرب العالميه الثانيه واتفقات
بريتنود ثم الخروج من هذه الاتفاقيات في
السبعينات همم في اوائل السبعينات وماذا
صالح للدولار ولا قطع صله بالذهب همم
كمبلغ كميه كذلك
ثمنينات في هذا في هذا النظام المالي
العالمي ووراءه كانت العديد من الافكار
الايجابيه صراحه يعني
تفعل الاستثمار الدفع للتشغيل المردوديه
وما الى ذلك في هذا كله ولكن اللي شفناها
ان هناك انحياز واصبح حتى اللي بغاليه
مشطه واثرت كثيرا على عديد من الشرائح بما
في ذلك الدول المتقدمه بدايه الملايين
واغلبيه الشرائح في الدول ال- الضعيفه اول
متوسط كيف الحلول ما هي الحلول هناك حلول
العمليه والهدف الاول او اننا نكون عندنا
قراءه سليمه سليمه لما صار في الازمات وفي
النظام عندنا قراءه استشرافيه لماذا
سيصيبه هناك رهانات كبيره في العالم كبيره
جدا يعني جاي وهو لازم مجلس حتى معنا في
نفس الطاوله الدول الكبرى وجميع الدول
والمنظمات الكبيره وهو همم والبنك الدولي
والصندوق النقد الدولي والكثير منها
والبنوك العالميه
همم
الميزانيات طبعا الدول التي تم يعني
اقراها في البرنامج يعني في سنه 2003
ميزانيات اللي همم التي جهز للاسلحه
الدفاع عن شفنا ارقام همم لا مثيل لها
التحديات التكنولوجيا وكل هذه التحديات
معك سعاده الوزير ولكن
عامه وحلول عالميه